the one thing I can assure you is is
that this story that I'm going to tell
you today is a kind of story you're not
going to hear from any other speaker
coming to this room and any other point
let me start out by telling you a little
bit about myself I was here at Stanford
20 years ago I'm actually back for my
20-year reunion which is what brought me
here today and and and so I thought
maybe I would share with you a little
bit of my own psychology when I was
sitting in these seats 20 years ago
probably when you hear me speaking one
of the questions that that would show up
in your mind is some what is this guy
with an American accent from Chicago
doing having been the at one point the
largest foreign portfolio investor in
Russia and what I will describe you in a
minute now one of the biggest enemies of
the state of Russia and and so let me
explain to you how that all happened
indeed I am an American I'm from Chicago
but I come from a very unusual family my
grandfather who is also American his
name is Earl Browder grew up in Wichita
Kansas and the family lost its fought
that the home in the farm in the 1920s
and he had to work in a factory and the
factory was mistreating their workers
and so he became a labor union organizer
and he's very good at it and so in after
working in Wichita he was recruited by
the Union to work in Kansas City then to
work in New York City
and in New York City there were various
communists so we're running around and
the Communists spotted him and said this
is a talented guy let's invite him to
Moscow and so the communist party
invited him to Moscow in 1927 he moved
to Moscow there um he met my grandmother
in Moscow and my father was born there
and then in 1932 he was sent back by the
Communist Party to America to become the
general secretary and head of the
Communist Party of America for the next
13 years
this is my grandfather so the McCarthy
era came in the 1950s and I'm sure you
all have know about that and so it
wasn't such an easy time to he got
kicked out of the Communist Party I
should say my grandfather in 1945 for
proposing that communism capitalism
could coexist and unfortunately many of
his followers in Eastern Europe were
assassinated he was fortunate living in
America that he wasn't and then he was
persecuted by McCarthy and had a very
terrible time even after being kicked
out of the Communist Party in the 1950s
so this is my family things normalized I
was born in 1964 some forty five years
old and I grew up in this in a
university community in the south side
of Chicago and I basically was just a
regular American kid and when I became a
teenager as often happens in American
families I decided to rebel against my
family but how do you rebel against a
family of Communists well I'll tell you
how I rebelled I put on a suit and tie
and became a businessman there was
nothing I could do to piss off my
parents more than that
and I came to Stanford Business School
and so I said in these rooms for two
years as many of you do and will be
doing and have done and and I went to
brown bag lunches and I went to
recruiting events trying to figure out
what I was going to do with my life and
some that something didn't quite feel
right because even though I was
rebelling against my family to become a
businessman I just didn't quite feel
right and so as I was searching my soul
to say what should I do with my life I
said what's my unique comparative
advantage with all these other people
that are also smart and also good and
also ambitious I thought well I I I'm a
businessman but I am also the grandson
of the head of the Communist Party
that's my competitive advantage and it
just so happened and it just so happened
that 1989 was the year that the Berlin
Wall came down and and so I had a chance
to do a business in the former communist
countries and guess what not a single
person I knew anywhere in the world had
any interest in doing it and so I showed
up I started looking for jobs where I
could be a doing business in Eastern
Europe and everyone said why would you
want to do that there's no business in
Eastern Europe and I looked for jobs and
look for jobs and people offered me all
sorts of mainstream normal jobs that
that I wanted to do business in Eastern
Europe and eventually I got a job at the
Boston Consulting Group in London and
they had a an eccentric partner there
who said that well we don't have any
business in Eastern Europe but if we
ever do you can be our guy you can be
the head of our Eastern European
practice
so I said okay that's as good as I'm
going to get so I went to London I went
to work at the Boston Consulting Group
and indeed a few months later we got a
nibble of work in Eastern Europe and the
the work we got was with a bus Factory
in Poland on the in the southeast corner
of Poland about six hours from Warsaw by
car on the Ukrainian border the bus
factory was being almost going out of
business they I think their sales
declined by 90 percent and somehow the
World Bank got involved and said we need
a consultant out here and BCG put in a
big proposal saying we have experts and
buses and we have experts and
manufacturing we have experts and all
these different things and the World
Bank's that great send them and so they
sent me as a first-year associate fresh
out of Stanford
so I go to this failing bus Factory and
it's pretty clear that there's no hope
for this bus factory if their sales are
declined by 90% they're just going to
have to layoff 90% of their employees or
they want to stay in business and so it
was not a very pleasurable assignment
but one thing happened to me while I was
sitting in this little town six hours
from Warsaw and I noticed that in the
newspaper that one day they had all
these financial statements in the middle
of the newspaper and I asked my
translator I didn't speak a word of
Polish I said what are these financial
statements and he said oh these are the
first these are the first privatizations
of the Polish government's doing I said
oh that's interesting
and I said so let's I said what does
this thing say what does this thing say
this we started to like write down the
numbers and basically they were selling
seven Polish companies at valuations
which were half of their one year
previous earnings okay now I wasn't
actually all that great a student at
Stanford but I bet I knew but even even
not being a great student I understood
that if you buy a company at half of one
year's earnings and that's got to make
sense right I mean and so and I didn't
have a lot of money I don't come from a
wealthy family or anything but I had
saved up four thousand bucks at that
point and I took my entire life savings
which is four thousand bucks I converted
into Polish thoughts Lottie I took it
down and I applied for shares in these
first privatizations and I bought them
and they went up ten times over the next
twelve months now if you've ever made
ten times your money on anything you'll
know that it releases a certain chemical
in your body
and and and you want that chemical
released again and so I knew I had found
my vocation I was going to go and buy it
into privatizations in Eastern Europe
so we fast forward a couple years and I
end up at Salomon Brothers and I'm
working and I got a job at Salomon
Brothers as an investment banker so I go
to work at Salomon Brothers there's
investment banker and so all my
brother's doesn't exist anymore it
became part of Citigroup and Citigroup
hardly exists or won't exist or whatever
but and I got to work a Salomon Brothers
and for those of you who have ever read
liars poker it's a great great book and
if you haven't you should and it talks
about the incredible culture of Salomon
Brothers which is this dog-eat-dog place
and I go to work at Salomon Brothers and
my on my first day at Salomon Brothers
not as an investment banker for Eastern
Europe they give me my business cards
they give me my desk and they say you
basically have to earn five times what
we're paying you or otherwise you're
going to get fired or earn it for the
firm get to work so I am there's no
training program there's no mentors
there's no here's what you need to do
get to work five times what we're paying
you otherwise you get fired so I hear
that there's a privatization of the
Hungarian airline and what there's some
team working on it and so I go to the
conference room where they're supposed
to be having a team meeting and I walk
in and they look at me and said what are
you doing here I said well I'm here to
help and they say we don't need your
help you know this is well taken care of
please leave because they didn't want to
share any of their five times with me
because that was just going to make
their life more difficult so no no
hungry I then heard about a Polish
telecom privatization going on a couple
days later and so I go and try to wedge
my way into that and they say don't even
think about coming in anywhere in near
Poland and I'm thinking how am I going
to ever survive in this firm and they're
extremely uncool and it was how am I
ever going to survive in this firm and
then I came up with this idea at the
time this was 1992 there was no
Investment Banking work in Russia and so
none of these guys were being trying to
protect their turf and so I just
declared myself the investment banker in
charge
of Russia because nobody nobody was and
there was nobody and and I declared it
waiting for somebody to object but
nobody objected because there was no
money there was just nothing going on
then I had an interesting opportunity
about three months into my investment
banking leadership in Russia
I got my first bite of a mandate and it
was a fishing fleet located in Murmansk
which was 300 miles north of the Arctic
Circle and this fishing fleet is called
the Murmansk roller fleet had had some
kind of fishing dispute with somebody
buying their fish and they had hired
Cleary Gottlieb to settle the dispute
and clearing Godley but the big New York
law firm had recommended that they hire
an investment banker to advise them on
privatization and so I went to the
library at Salomon Brothers and
discovered that like 20 years before
Salomon Brothers had done some fishing
deals in Japan and I proudly put these
into into a presentation to the Murmansk
trawler fleet and lo and behold they
called us up and said you've won the the
assignment please come in and and
negotiate fees and so I started getting
in touch with them to negotiate fees and
and and it turned out that they're ready
to pay fifty thousand dollars a month
for two months to advise on their entire
privatization now there's not an
investment banker that would get out of
bed for fifty thousand bucks for two
months or for a month but it was fifty
five thousand dollars greater than zero
which is what I had earned so far is the
head of the Russian investment banking
business and so I took the assignment
and I and I got on a plane to Murmansk
and I got got to Murmansk which is a
very very desolate terrible place really
just a horrible place and I sat down
with the head of the fishing fleet and I
asked him what's going on how could I
help and he's any he walked me through
the math and they they basically had a
hundred ships each ship cost twenty
million dollars new so there's two
billion dollars worth of ships maybe
seven years old in total so about half
depreciated so a billion dollars worth
of ships and he had hired me to decide
whether the management should exercise
their right under the privatization
program to purchase 50
1% of this fleet for two and a half
million dollars so it's actually quite
an easy assignment you know and again
you didn't have to be a Stanford MBA to
advise on this stuff five million market
cap a billion dollars with their ships
Wow so but I you know I had that
chemical reaction that I had from from
Poland sort of pumping through my system
at this point
and I thought to myself I want to get
involved in some of this this stuff and
and so the first thing I did after
leaving there was I instead of going
back to London I went to Moscow to see
whether whether this was just an anomaly
in this fishing fleet or whether the
whole situation was the same all over
Russia and it turned out that that the
entire Russia was being put through the
same type of privatization program and
and what I learned I I didn't know a
soul in Moscow I didn't speak a word of
Russian and I got hold of an English
language yellow page directory that they
had for English language business
visitors and I just started circling
people in the yellow page directory and
going around meeting them and I met
about 30 people and I over the course of
a week I put together the the the the
sort of thought about what this is and
it was very simple that they had
vouchers that they gave to every person
in the country and their 150 million
people in the country in each voucher
cost 20 bucks and so that gave you three
billion dollars worth of vouchers and
that was exchangeable for 30% of all the
share capital of all the shares in
Russia which meant the entire value of
Russia in 1992 was 10 billion dollars
for the whole country all the oil all
the gas all the metals all the
everything ten billion dollars and boy
at this point the adrenaline was just
pumping through my system and I it was
clear that this was this the most
unbelievable unbelievable opportunity
ever so I go back to Salomon Brothers
were I had been working and I say listen
we're wasting our time with all this
$50,000 advisory stuff we should get in
there buy some of this stuff and we'll
make a fortune there's good there's
giving it away gold for free and and
they looked at me like I was completely
out of my mind and and I thought how
could people say well Russia invest in
Russia what are you crazy
and and the more people and I didn't
know how to work an organization or
politics or anything and so the more the
more that they the more people sort of
blanked me and and didn't want to talk
about it the more I would just like try
to find somebody else who would listen
to me and so I was just talking to more
and more people which was exactly the
wrong thing to do in an organization
where that starts going on and so pretty
soon I used to have these group lunches
about the young guys who all were the
same year and like people stopped
inviting me to the group lunches no more
no more drinks you know no people didn't
want to be seen with me I was some kind
of eccentric outcast and I wasn't
earning any money for the firm either
that five-times thing was coming close
to being due so I was I was in this
terrible situation of becoming like an
outcast in the firm and very unpopular
and my job was on the line I was feeling
very bad about myself
and one day I got a call from a very
senior person in the New York office
who's responsible for the firm's balance
sheet he said I heard that you might
have something interesting to say about
Russia why don't you come in and tell me
about it and so I am I prepare myself
PowerPoint presentation so hopefully I
can somehow get through to this guy and
maybe turn my situation around so I go
to New York and this guy is meeting with
was a very very strange fellow with no
social graces whatsoever and he was like
one of their most successful investors
in the firm but nobody could ever work
on his team for long because he just had
no he was just a not a not a character
to work with and so I go and sit down
with him and I and I started taking him
through my PowerPoint presentation
showing these numbers that I've just
shared with you and he wasn't nodding or
giving me any kind of feedback he was
just looking at it really blankly that's
going through my PowerPoint page after
page and no no feedback no no response
no nothing and I am and I'm starting to
feel a little worried and about halfway
through my presentation he just gets up
and leaves the room without saying a
word
and I'm sitting there and I'm thinking
to myself this is not good this is this
is probably my last chance of getting
you know doing this and I'm trying to
think about what I'm going to say when
he comes back to this to this room so I
can somehow salvage it and I'm getting
more and more worked up trying to think
how can i how can I pull this out
because you know this is my this is my
whole dream this is this is this is how
it's going to work and he comes back and
before I have a chance of my mouth he
said this is the most unbelievable story
I've ever heard I've just gone to the
Risk Committee and I've got an
allocation for you to invest 25 million
dollars stop all this nonsense you're
doing with Investment Banking we're
gonna invest in this stuff this is
amazing all of a sudden a big cloud and
a big weight has been lifted off my
shoulders I go back to London and I
start investing
I gotta learn and get up get my stuff
organized I then go to Moscow and we
start investing this 25 million dollars
which was an enormous amount of money
for the Russian market back then and we
get the 25 million dollars invested and
seven months later now we're in the
middle of 1994 The Economist magazine
writes an article which outlines the
same economics I've just taken you
through it's called sale of the century
and all of a sudden about 30 people rich
guys a few hedge funds wake up and say
God we should be invested in this thing
and so they start calling up brokers or
whoever to try to get invested and our
25 million dollar portfolio in that
seven month period because of this
economists article went up five times in
seven months because of it because of
because all of a sudden 30 people showed
up to start buying this stuff so I've
gone from 25 to 125 million and this was
back in the days when a hundred million
was a lot of money
and so all of a sudden all the guys who
weren't inviting me to lunch and weren't
inand weren't hanging out with me
anymore start coming around my desk
saying bill you know how could we get
involved in this Russian stuff and I'd
like to buy some of this stuff in my
personal account and literally every
morning there was like four guys hanging
around my desk before I arrived waiting
to get some advice on how they could
make some of this money in Russia but
more importantly than that the the
senior salespeople who had like big
hedge fund clients at Salomon Brothers
started coming around and saying you
know we don't you'd be willing to come
to New York and meet George Soros nobody
know could you meet john templeton
michael Steinhardt so i was like in my
late twenties and I was being invited to
meet the most successful investors on on
earth to explain to them what I've done
in Russia so I am I go to these meetings
and I take them through my PowerPoint
and every single one of them says at the
end of the meeting that's the most
amazing thing I've ever heard can we
give you some money to manage I said
well we're not actually in the business
of managing anyone's money let me go
back and ask my colleagues and see
whether we can we can do this so I get
back and I asked my boss in London if
this is something that we can do for
other people it's a great idea for sure
let's form a task force to study it so I
so he said next Monday will be the first
taskforce meeting so I show up to the
taskforce meeting and it's like this
room there's like 50 people showed up
for the first task force meeting and
there's only like two people in the firm
who knew anything about about Russia and
I look around the room and people start
and there was like directors and
managing directors and senior managing
directors and I was like some junior
vice president and I was looking around
the room and I and all these guys were
sort of arguing with each other about
which part that firm was going to get
the credit for this and who's going to
get the money I was looking around
thinking myself I know there's one thing
I know for sure who's not going to get
any money out of this thing
so I got really angry and I went back
and I was tossing and turning for a few
days and I just I said this is I just
can't do this and so I sucked up my gut
and I went into the head of the trading
floor and say I'm quitting I'm going to
set up my own fund to do this
he said bill you're crazy you have such
a promising career sorry I'm setting up
my own fund to do this and I went I left
Salomon Brothers and I set up my fund
called The Hermitage fund and I went
back to all of these some famous guys
who I met on Wall Street and I said
would you be willing to invest with me
in my Hermitage fund and one of the guys
who I'd met was a very famous now
deceased man named Edmond Safra he was
the owner of Republic National Bank in
New York and in the world of private
banking his name was as good as it ever
that his name was like a legend in
private banking you might not know about
him now but if you knew the history of
wealth and private banking this man was
just like gold and Edmond Safra put up
the first 25 million dollars to be my
anchor investor we became joint venture
partners and he said if you do a good
job with this 25 million then I will
introduce you to all the rich people in
the world and will make you into a
spectacular success but you need to do a
good job first so I moved to Moscow from
London in 1996 and start investing and
it was really a very interesting thing
because in 1996 there was not a single
Wall Street educated in principle
investor who was actually sitting on the
ground in Russia there's a lot of Wall
Street principal investors sitting on
the ground and Wall Street and there was
a lot of Wall Street educated brokers
sitting on the ground in Moscow but no
investors and it's very interesting cuz
the brokers would all right research
about things that they could make a lot
of commissions buying and selling and
they wouldn't write research about the
things that made the most sense and so
basically you end up in a situation
where anything any stock that was
researched by the brokers would trade at
ten times evaluation of any stock in the
same industry that wasn't researched by
the brokers and nobody had any
confidence in buying the stuff that
wasn't researched because they couldn't
do any research so again this is not
rocket science this is just simple
simple stuff
I thought well here I am on the ground I
can do my own research why don't I go
visit the company that trades at 1/10
evaluation of the other one where
there's a research report so I went and
visited the oil company that traded at
1/10 the valuation of Lukoil and a
couple of them that did and I looked at
them and there was no difference between
the ones that were 1/10 evaluation
except for the fact that there's what
wasn't a credit Swiss research report so
after going through these companies and
realizing that they're exactly the same
they the same surly management the same
rusting oil derricks the same bad tax
inspectors the same everything one was
10 times cheaper than the other and by
the way the one that was 10 times more
expensive was still 1/10 evaluation of
the Western oil company so these are
trading 1/100 of valuation of the
Western oil companies so I decided I'm
gonna invest in the stuff that's
unresearched because I can do my own
research so I did my own research
invested in them and my fund went up in
the first month of operations that went
up 35% nothing not in a year but in a
month so some of Edmond Safra clients
are heard about that he was into this
hot new thing in Russia and wanted to
get involved they called up Edmond and
said can we invest in your fund he said
no no no we don't know this guy he could
be stupid he could be a crook we have no
idea I want to audit I want to have like
a year's track record audits everything
and then I'll let everybody in but I
don't want to put my name next to his
until I know for sure that he's he's a
solid guy the next month we're up 40%
and the guys who had called him say
Edmond what are you trying to do your
that was 40% we would have made if we
had been vested and people were getting
angry with him and said listen ed and
we're going to take some of our money
out of your bank if you're being so
greedy and not letting us into this
thing just keeping it for yourself and
he couldn't have imagined that his
business risk was not going to be me
blowing up and me doing too well and so
all these people were going to
threatening to leave his bank because he
I had done so well he wouldn't let him
in and so he relented opened up the fund
for outside investors and by the end of
the first year we had about a hundred
million dollars under management
we got put like one hundred and fifty
percent the next year was even better we
were up to two hundred and I think we're
up two hundred and forty two percent in
1997 we were up eight hundred percent
from when we launched 18 months earlier
my fund was over a billion dollars again
this is when a billion dollars really
meant something and I was the largest
investor by any stretch of the
imagination in a small market they were
writing articles about how clever I was
in the front page of the New York Times
my clients were biting me their yachts
I was in my early 30s I thought that I
thought I've just figured it all out I
and I had no perspective I mean
everything that I just told you was like
it you know one of them by themselves
might not have been a cell signal but
you know a young guy in his 30s with the
biggest Fund in a market up eight
hundred percent in 18 months clients and
yachts front page articles that is a
sell signal if there ever was one but I
was too young and too inexperienced to
understand that in 1997 the the Asian
currency started to devalue Asian
markets started to go down the Russians
Russian bought the Russian government
had a huge debt burden it was rolling on
a three-month basis with hedge funds and
rich guys and they couldn't roll it over
Russia defaulted devalued the stock
market went down 88 percent my 1 billion
went down to 100 million there was no
more yachts invitations after that but
then I discovered something far more
disturbing than losing ninety percent of
your money which was that the the
companies that I invested in with
basically oil and gas companies in
Russia were run by people who you've now
who are now sort of properly
immortalized the Russian oligarchs these
a small group of about 22 guys basically
owned a majority of all these companies
and they used to behave themselves a
little bit when they thought they had a
that they needed access to Western
capital when the Western capital markets
were open but after the Russian economy
defaulted and devalued and everything
went to hell there was no more Western
investors in any case and so they no
longer had any need to behave themselves
and so in 1998 and 1999 the Russian
oligarchs embarked on an orgy of
stealing that's been unprecedented in
the history of business I mean it's just
remarkable every type of scam you could
ever imagine they were trying to do
asset stripping transfer pricing
dilution embezzlement you name it they
were doing it and I was owning one or
two percent of these companies and just
watching all the money that the
companies had just disappearing and so I
had to decide something I either either
is going to stay there and just put up
with all this stuff or I was going to
have to I mean but I mean basically
there was there was there was really
only two choices you could either leave
or you could fight I mean I could not
just watch it happen and so we decided
to fight and and the most famous fight
involved gasps prom and gasps prom is a
company that no one had really heard of
in the West until like ten years ago but
and gas from is it's the biggest gas
company in the world it's about ten
times the size of Exxon in terms of
hydrocarbon reserves and gas prom in
1999 was trading at a ninety nine point
seven percent discount to BP or Exxon
per barrel of hydrocarbon reserves why
was it at such a big discount because
everybody thought that everything that
everything was being stolen out of gas
prom so I looked at this thing and I
said to myself could they really be
stealing everything out of gas prom that
would be just the most remarkable thing
a company ten times the size of Exxon
everything being stolen so I got
together with my team and I said let's
do a stealing analysis of gas from and
they looked at me how do you do a
stealing analysis so we think we sort of
think oh how do you do a stealing
analysis and and as I said in the
introduction
they don't didn't teach me this at
Stanford Business School um you couldn't
go to the company and say how much he's
stealing because they wouldn't tell you
that might do worse things you couldn't
go to the brokers because the brokers
are so busy preening themselves in front
of gas from to get corporate finance
work that the last thing they would do
is tell anybody how much stealing was
going on but I learned something as a
consultant at the Boston Consulting
Group which is some if you want to find
out the answer to something which is not
written down somewhere you just go and
interview people that's what the
consultants do for any of you thinking
about consulting and so I said let's
make a list of all the people who know
about stealing a gas prom and just ask
them to breakfast lunch dinner tea
coffee and see what we can learn from
interviewing them
we didn't know whether anyone would
accept our invitations or tell us
anything but why not try so we set up
about 40 of these meals and most people
accepted the invitation why not and we
discovered something very interesting is
that in the communist days the richest
person in Russia was maybe 10 times
richer than the poorest person but by
1999 the richest person in Russia was
like 250,000 times richer than the
poorest person and that just poisoned
the whole environment of the country
everyone just hated everybody else and
hated the rich people and hated this
people that stole and so people were in
these meetings we're spilling their guts
out to us about all the different scams
they knew about we were filling up
notebooks with all these different
allegations of scams as interesting
really interesting stuff people were
telling us writing it all down we filled
up a whole notebook with these
allegations but how do you know any deaf
is true you know a lot of sour grapes
now Russia has one other great
interesting anomaly which is it's got to
be the most bureaucratic country in the
world everything that ever happens in
Russia gets filed in quadruplicate in
four different ministries and you go to
the bathroom you have to write down and
then some ministry like registers it and
so and what's interesting is that you
can just go and ask for the information
just a question of like going to the
ministry and so one of my guys one of
one of the guys works for me my head of
research started going around to
different ministries picking up
databases on different things and we
were able to take these databases we got
from the ministries and cross-reference
them with all the stuff we learned in
these breakfast lunches and dinners and
we learned exactly how much had been
stolen from gas prom by who in what way
and basically what we learned was that
nine individuals from management of gas
prom had stolen an oil company the size
of Exxon at a gas prom that's pretty
dramatic I mean well that's the size of
Kuwait that oil reserves the size of
Kuwait had been stolen out of gas from
but we also learned that some at the oil
company the size of Kuwait is only 9% of
gas prawns reserves
91% was still there so what do you do if
the markets pricing something is if
there's a ninety-nine point seven
percent discount and you've just
discovered that really there should only
be a ten percent discount you go and buy
the hell out of the thing and that's
what we did we made gas from our single
largest investment that's usually where
a fund manager would stop but we said to
ourselves this is just so morally
outrageous what these guys have done and
it's so obvious let's share this
information with the world and so we did
we broke into seven chapters I gave a
chapter to the Financial Times a chapter
to the Wall Street Journal
chapter to the New York Times
Businessweek and each of them wrote a
story and boy did that set the Moscow
night on fire
there were parliamentary hearings there
were there were shareholder votes there
was articles more articles more hearings
investigations and about seven months
later Putin who had become president in
1999 stepped in fired the head of gas
prom put a new guy in who said his
responsibility was to recover the lost
assets and not let any more gas from
assets leave the company and from the
moment that we started this thing until
2005
the stock price was up a hundred times
we got so excited by this that we
started doing it elsewhere we did at the
unified energy systems the national
electricity company we did it at spear
bank the National Savings Bank we did it
at some sort of NAFTA gas and it was
working like a charm not everything was
as remarkable as gas prompt it was all
pretty pretty amazing the fund went up
something like 40 times from from we
went from a hundred million to more than
four billion I became the largest
investor in Russia it was just amazing
and now I'm going to show you a video
from for the last ten minutes
what happened next because the video is
better than I could ever I could ever do
it it's the true Kafka desk type of
situation it's black as white white is
black um it's the most unbelievable
thing you could ever imagine it's one
thing to be victimized of a crime it's
another thing to then be blamed for the
crime that you're a victim of the
following is a story so extraordinary
you couldn't make it up a story about
the risks of investing in Russia today a
story about how companies are stolen
criminals takeover banks and murderers
dictate to judges about how politicians
pay lip service to cleaning up the
system but in fact do nothing or
actively assist the criminals
it's a story whose twists and turns lead
down a dark trail of corruption violence
and the theft of two hundred and thirty
million dollars from the Russian people
crimes like the one we're about to
describe happen in Russia every day
and this is how it can happen Hermitage
Capital Management's is an investment
firm that started 1996 to focus on the
Russian equity market and I founded it
in partnership with late Edmond Safra
and we were the largest foreign
portfolio investor in Russia everything
had been going beautifully with the
business we had been growing the fund we
had been making money for our investors
we had been stamping out corruption in
the companies we invested in but as
often happens when you step on enough
toes eventually people certain people
get angry with you on November the 13th
2005 when he was returning home to
Moscow from a business trip Bill Browder
was refused entry at the airport later
he was told by the Russian authorities
but he'd been banned from the country on
the grounds of national security I then
tried using every friend and contact I
have to get back into Russia I had an
interesting opportunity I was attending
the World Economic Forum in Davos in
January 2007 and Dmitry Medvedev who is
now the president was then the first
Deputy Prime Minister was making his
official foreign debut and at the forum
I had an opportunity to have a brief
conversation with him where I asked him
for help in restoring my visa
and he was responsive he said he would
help he asked for a copy of my visa
application I thought with the help of
the first Deputy Prime Minister my visa
would be approved in no time at all what
happened next was very different from
what bill had expected dental leftenant
colonel art encodes nets off of the tax
crimes unit of the Moscow Ministry of
the Interior who a few weeks after bill
Browder's appeal to the first Deputy
Prime Minister Medvedev to reissue his
entry visa telephoned Hermitage
lieutenant colonel our team kuznetsov
called up my head of research and he
said to him i understand that the CEO of
your company wishes to get a visa to
visit our country and i'm responsible
for writing the report but before i
write the report
i'd like to have an informal meeting
show you a few papers ask a few
questions depending on how you behave
and what you provide in this meeting
would be the determining factor in
whether the visa gets issued Hermitage
rejected this extortion attempt and
refused to meet or talk with food
schnitzel
but could Smets off at his own plans On
June the 4th 2007
leftenant Colonel could Smets off led a
team of 25 officers in a raid on the
Hermitage Moscow offices taking servers
computers and documents the official
reason he gave for this raid was the one
of the Hermitage companies Khmer had
supposedly under paid dividend
withholding tax
this was not true not only had Kamiya
paid up its tax but the Russian tax
authorities certified in writing that it
had overpaid them by as much as four
million rubles in addition to whose Nets
off rating our offices he then joined an
ongoing raid on the same day at the
offices of our law firm Firestone Duncan
one of their young lawyers protested
instead of trying to explain whatever
their legal logic was they took him into
a conference room beat him viciously
arrested him for resisting the search he
was fined 15,000 rubles to get out of
jail and then he was in hospital for two
weeks having to recover from his beating
in fact Goods nets offs raids were the
first part of the criminals plan a
fishing expedition to find out the
amount of Hermitage's assets and in
which banks they were held at the same
time
Kuznetsov seized all of Hermitage's
corporate documents and certificates
these official documents would be used
by the criminals to steal the Hermitage
companies what happened next
occurred without Hermitage knowing the
criminals went to the Russian courts in
Kazan some Petersburg and Moscow and
obtained judgments against the Hermitage
companies on the basis of forged
contracts they even use real lawyers
armed with bogus powers of attorney to
represent the Hermitage companies
instead of defending the Hermitage
companies the lawyers pleaded guilty
logos plus and two other companies
belonging to the criminals were
fraudulently awarded hundreds of
millions of dollars by the course later
Hermitage discovered for the three
individuals who had been installed as
the new directors of the stolen
companies were criminals viktor makarov
a convicted murderer
Yurika Rajan a convicted thief and the
Ash's love clip Nick off a convicted
burglar all three had been released from
jail early by the Russian authorities in
total three companies were stolen from
the Hermitage fund according to the sham
court judgments together the companies
allegedly owed nearly 1.3 billion
dollars to the criminals companies the
criminals could not have stolen the
Hermitage companies or secured the
judgments against them without the
corporate documents and certificates
seized by codes nets off in his raid of
June the fourth and supposedly kept in
his safe custody since then armed with
the Sham judgments the criminals sent
could snits off to the banks to seize
the assets the one thing that this group
of criminals hadn't bargained on was
that there will be no assets there so
they put millions of dollars into the
scam bribing different officials bribing
judges getting all sorts of people
involved in this thing and they got
nothing and so for a brief period of
time we felt very relieved and happy
that they got nothing and that was the
end of the story but it wasn't phase 2
of the criminals fraud was to steal a
two hundred and thirty million dollars
of tax money already paid by Hermitage
to the Russian authorities by claiming a
tax rebate this they did through the
brilliant ruse of demonstrating that the
1.3 billion dollars of alleged debt
which resulted from a sham Court
judgments had wiped out Hermitage EES
profits in 2006 within a mere three days
of submitting the claim of 24th of
December 2007 Algar 2-z may and Sergey
exempt kuzmic off officials of the
Russian tax office authorized a
staggeringly huge tax repayment of two
hundred and thirty million dollars to
the criminals the largest single tax
repayment in Russian history was made
without a single question being asked
two hundred and thirty million dollars
which belonged to the Russian people had
been stolen by the criminals in an
organized conspiracy supported by
corrupt officials in the higher reaches
of the Russian state the Russian tax
authorities paid the money into the
criminals accounts at to obscure banks
Universal savings and Inter comets they
covered their tracks they laundered the
money and filed to liquidate the stolen
Hermitage company's Hermitage filed
dozens of complaints at every level of
the Russian state not a single
institution or person on the special
anti-corruption committee set up by
President Medvedev has looked into the
fraud against Hermitage the most absurd
part of the whole thing is is that the
only the only complaint that got any
traction was one which we sent to the
Russian state Investigative Committee
and and what traction did that get they
blamed us for the tax crime meanwhile
the bill Browder matters took a further
turn for the worse
bill Browder has been put on the federal
search list for standing up to
corruption and organized crime you can't
steal two hundred and thirty million
dollars from the Russian budget without
having very very senior officials
involved clearly we can see the names of
the senior law enforcement officials
going right up the chain we can also see
the involvement of senior tax officials
senior judges lawyers and then on top of
that you have all the people that we
wrote to that decided to do nothing
about it
and that tells you something
as this video is being produced the
Russian Ministry of the Interior police
have arrested Sergei Magnitsky a lawyer
and accountant working on Hermitage
affairs of the Moscow based law firm
Firestone Dunkin six other Russian
lawyers working for Hermitage who've
been trying to seek justice by reporting
the 230 million dollar tax fraud to the
Russian authorities have either fled
Russia or have gone into hiding so a
story's so extraordinary you couldn't
make it up the story about the risks of
investing in Russia today a story that
sounds like a thriller but isn't it's a
true story and it's one that's being
repeated every day